there's an absolute insane development
in the science and technology world that
you're not going to believe the very
first u.s patient ever just got a brand
new computer chip implanted into their
brain this is a historic development and
humanity will never be the same it's
important to understand that this is a
medical procedure trying to treat a
patient with als but the promise of this
technology is that eventually it can be
brought to everyday people to try to
augment and enhance their brain
functions now as i mentioned this is a
historic day for humanity as more people
start to understand this technology and
we begin to get more and more data as to
what this technology allows for and how
it can actually enhance the way that
humans interact with their brain their
thoughts and their intelligence i
wouldn't be surprised to see this become
a major field to improve humans
capabilities and to also drive more
economic productivity globally now let's
jump in and make sure we understand
exactly what's happening here on july
6th according to ashley vance over at
bloomberg a doctor at mount sinai west
medical center in new york put a 1.5
inch long implant made up of wires and
electrodes into a blood vessel in the
brain of a patient with als
the hope is that the patient who's lost
the ability to move and speak will be
able to surf the web and communicate via
email and text simply by thinking that
device will translate his thoughts into
commands sent to a computer
synchron which is the startup behind the
technology they've already done this to
four patients in australia and there's
been no side effects and those
individuals have been able to carry out
such tasks as sending whatsapp messages
and making online purchases
the recent procedure in the united
states was the first for a company here
within our borders this puts them ahead
of competitors like elon musk's neural
link and according to the neuro
interventional surgeon who performed the
surgery he said this surgery was special
because of its implications and huge
potential
now just the idea of this technology is
a really big deal but the way they do it
will absolutely blow your mind what's
occurring here is a brain computer
interface which is a device known as a
stentrode that can be inserted into the
brain without cutting through a person's
skull or damaging their tissue a doctor
makes an incision into the patient's
neck and it feeds the sphinctrote the
catheter through the jugular vein into a
blood vessel nestled within the motor
cortex as the catheter is removed the
device which is basically a hollow wire
mesh opens up and begins to fuse with
the outer edges of the vessel
according to the surgeon the process is
very similar to implanting a coronory
stent and takes just a few minutes
now as we continue to see this
technology push forward and as ashley
vance over at bloomberg points out so
eloquently this can have major
implications on humanity
imagine a world where we not only can go
in and cure or help to soften the impact
of something like als
but what happens when now we may not
need to actually talk or to type or to
communicate in traditional means by
simply thinking you'll be able to get
things done
now there's one aspect of the
conversation where people say i don't
want that i'm worried what if people
could spam me what if they could ddos my
brain and what if i actually like
talking or i like getting things done
the old-fashioned way
of course if this technology proves
viable that will take decades and
decades to come to fruition but at the
end of these types of experiments what
we find is that technology has been a
net positive for humanity and if we are
able to find a way to augment and
enhance human intelligence by using
technology people will do it companies
like synchron neural link and others are
all pushing the boundaries of what's
possible and now we see the very first
patient in the united states to receive
an implant of a brain computer interface
this was a dream of technologists and
medical professionals just a few years
ago but now it is becoming reality
be fascinating to continue to watch how
this plays out where people think we
should go ahead and insert the
technology next and what the potential
impact both positive and negative will
be in the future brain computer
interfaces are at the cutting edge of
technology innovation experimentation
and the medical field the promise is
large the experiments are happening now
and i can't wait to see what ends up
being possible